Before we move on to two certs let's look at a
few
terminology consider the eighth root of a n is
called the order and the index so when we are
taking the cube root the order will be
three this root sign v c is called the
radical and the number  Under the radical is called
the radican and the base this number is set as the eighth
root of a In the previous video we saw the
irrational root of a positive rational number
means numbers like the square root of 3 and the
cube root of 5 The answer we got  is irrational and the
base is a positive rational
number so the irrational root of a positive rational
number is called a surd those examples are surds remember the answer is to be
irrational and the
decade of the base is to be a positive rational
number it me that  The Root of 4 and the Cube
Root of 8 Let's take a look at Rational
Numbers Now let's look at the basic
classification How are real numbers
classified It's simple They are classified into two
types Rational and Irrational Numbers
Within irrational numbers we have numbers like
Root of cube root 7 root 5 and then there
is another section of rational numbers
other special numbers like pa and e which is your
number this category of irrational numbers are called
surds There is a common
misunderstanding that all irrational numbers are
surds but ts  Incorrect Remember Only an Irrational
Root of a Positive Rational Number is a
Surd